entre aplausos de sus amigos karim de 6
años recibe su primera dosis de la
vacuna contra el cob y 19 como el 28
millones de estadounidenses de entre 5 y
11 años ya son elegibles para recibir el
fármaco the fighter
realmente no hace daño pero háganlo por
el bien de eeuu porque esto es ayudar a
eeuu y al mundo y que la vida sea mejor
para todas y cada una de las personas
del planeta
las autoridades aprobaron el fármaco
para los pequeños el martes alegando que
el riesgo de efectos secundarios graves
es menor en los niños además el virus
tiene fuertes impactos en la salud
mental de la población infantil y agravó
las desigualdades en el acceso a la
educación la vacuna también se aplica en
dos dosis con tres semanas de diferencia
entre cada una pero la cantidad aplicada
es sólo una tercera parte de la usada
para adolescentes y niños un estudio
reciente de los centros de control y
prevención de enfermedades señala que de
entre mil padres el 57% declaro que
vacunar a sus hijos
creo completamente en la vacuna en la
ciencia he leído artículos donde
explican que los beneficios superan los
posibles efectos secundarios
sin embargo algunos padres discrepan la
principal preocupación es el riesgo de
inflamación del corazón detectado en
adolescentes y jóvenes después de
vacunarse con facer o modernas
no creo que ningún padre deba poner esto
en el cuerpo de sus hijos en eeuu más de
8.300 personas de entre 5 y 11 años han
sido hospitalizadas por kobe 19 de entre
las cuales un tercio precisó cuidados
intensivos según los datos del gobierno